now we're bringing our discussions about
african-americans and the particular
denominations the traditions that
Pournami those among african-american
communities largely Protestant ones to
to a close as well in this chapter so we
don't have to do a lot of review but
there is some review to do you know the
back story because there's gonna be
certain events that are particularly key
what would they be for understanding why
african-american is harder than what
churches they they're in for example or
why african-american Christianity is
discussed as something distinct is it is
it just that well you know every race
needs to have its own particular version
of Christianity we don't talk about
Asian Christianity doing or Chinese
Christianity there are you know Chinese
Christians why you know why is it so
distinctive where should we start
yeah okay so we start out with slavery
and the South right what is now
officially the Emancipation Proclamation
but what really ends up yeah yeah Civil
War
South loses North wind's
so the regime of slavery comes to an end
they go through this period that they
call reconstruction which was a very
turbulent time the economy of the South
had been largely devastated there there
were a lot of forces attempting to sort
of re-imposed the old order back on the
south at the same time there were
northern abolitionists who wanted to try
to create a new order and the
african-american sort of caught in the
middle wanting something better for
themselves and quite often you know
being being subject to a lot of violence
and abuse this goes on the
reconstruction doesn't last very long
but the new sort of system in the South
goes on for for quite a while you're
right quite a few of them go to the
north
so let's actually put like sort of a
split here in some sense we can talk
about different African American
experiences in different parts of the
country what does it mean to go to to
the north
why are wearing African Americans is
leaving the song just because like this
is you know this is nonsense down here
we're not going to put up with this sort
of stuff let's get let's get out of here
all right so there's the possibility of
economic prosperity and when we talk
about the North we're not just talking
about the big northern cities we're also
talking about immigration into you know
the cities of the plain states like like
in Kansas there's the this entire
development for a while and sometimes
it's stymied by violence you know a
black middle-class that's that's where
some of these these race riots you know
turned they they were successful in the
north there were jobs it was possible
now what put the kibosh on there what
what created a lot of problems whether
you're black white you know Asian
anything because the prosperity didn't
go on forever
it's been so long past even our
grandparents a Great Depression it'll
run it through the 1930s and then either
of the wartime years and eventually we
start to see you know all these
discussions of integration civil rights
emerging in the 1960s what's happening
in the south during after the Civil War
but you know say before the 1960s
whatever what is what are the things
from influencing African American
prospects yeah nation yeah incredibly
pervasive regime segregation I mean you
guys have all seen the images of the
bathrooms and drinking fountains the
sharecropping
which essentially print you know a month
to a new type of servitude sharecropping
meant that that you would have to work
at somebody else's land and you wouldn't
you'd never be able to own it because
we'd actually have to get a lot of you
know what you produce on that land to
the person who owns and you might also
be in debt to them for all the equipment
that you're using with the seed that
you're using and they would get the bulk
of it so this is a way to keep people in
is something I can you know you couldn't
even say indentured servitude because
indentured servitude and after 7 or 14
years this could people could keep
people in servitude for generations and
then others is what they call the Jim
Crow regime which includes you know
segregation and things like that but
also has to do with with keeping African
Americans from being able to
sighs the power of the vote you know
having poll taxes or things like that
two very different experiences yeah the
north and the south are rather different
from each other was their segregation in
in the north
let's see ask about that both after the
war and before the war yes there was
some segregation we're going to see that
that plays an important role in church
formation for some african-american
denominations what about after the war
after there's a lot of black immigration
to the to the north
segregation exists does you know in
large part particularly in the big
cities I know when I was a kid and I
grew up you know not in Milwaukee but on
the outskirts you know out in the
country what we call Greater Milwaukee
one of the big controversies that the
day was should children from you know
Waukesha County be bused into Milwaukee
County largely white children from the
you know more prosperous areas into
these urban schools and should black
children be bussed out correlative Lee
talking about bus rides of like an extra
hour or maybe two each day and there was
intense opposition to it it was called
desegregation because there was a lot of
segregation there still is actually
quite a bit of segregation as far as
race goes in Milwaukee even to this day
largely economic economically driven
it's still there
considered white in every other context
only you her an estate that was
incredibly racist it was my grandfather
who was lighter than me but he had an
afro he was a barber and they told them
to get out of the shop and work at the
Negro barber shop because he couldn't
fit in you know when I worked in Indiana
State Prison I was it was really
interesting to find out that the Indiana
Department of Corrections listed only
three races and it was black white and
other because the only races I really
you know mattered as far as race was
concerned were black and white Indians
kind of southern state in what respects
culturally yeah I mean this doesn't go
down in the north as well now what's the
sort of up shudders well there is this
intense in you know imposition of
difference and the question is what are
they going to do with that and then how
does that affect their religious life
how does that affect their approach to
to God in community in terms of how
they're going to live their lives how
they're going to worship and your book
talks about several different major
let's call them denominational
traditions for African Americans
these resulted in many cases in what we
call historically black churches just
let me talk about some universities as
being historically black colleges or
universities foremost among these are
Methodist Church and Diana church and
both of these which are very similar to
each other are formed precisely they're
formed in the north and their form
precisely out of the experience of
segregation over the experience of not
being able to sort of benefit from the
the investment of labor in the things it
talks about Richard Alan Richard Alan
and his black colleagues attempted to
participate fully in worship at st.
George's Methodist Church in
Philadelphia now notice the date
November 1787 so we're going back a very
very long ways they collectively
withdraw from the church and they formed
this network of black churches that
paralleled the whites and nominations
eventually he founds the Bethel African
Methodist Episcopal Church and we get
you know one of these denominations out
of that there were other important
Methodist denomination originally
colored Methodist Episcopal Church now
called the Christian Methodist Episcopal
Church founded in 1870 by southern
blacks who wanted to leave the Methodist
Episcopal
Episcopal Church south why because that
is good from its northern
co-religionists over the question of
slavery whatever what other
denominations that really attracted
yes yeah in some respects they've been
more successful if we won't look at the
sheer numbers alone
Baptists were one of the major religious
groups in the south along with
Methodists and along with you know
Presbyterians there is by the way one
african-american Presbyterian Church but
it's not very large but the actus here
we're talking about some some really
major denominations I'm just gonna put
down nbc's by the sakura to understand
the various National Baptist
Convention's because there were splits
within it with different organizations
retaining the name and you know
distinguishing themselves from each
other in fairly minor ways and then
there was the progressive National
Baptist Convention as well thinking
about what you know about Baptists why
would this be particularly attractive
after the Civil War for
african-americans in the south
what do you need to start a Baptist
Church in addition to come in do you
need you know overseers and a whole
institutional structure like you do with
Methodists it's a very ground-up kind of
kind of movement so it's it's pretty
easy to build new churches to spread
quite often you didn't have to be you
know the Methodists were a bit more
demanding and what they expected in
training of ministers then Baptists were
although there are some really great
Baptist seminaries it's interesting too
because after the Civil War
book doesn't talk about this there's a
lot of let's call it not quite conflict
but very hot discussions amongst African
Americans in the South about which
churches they think ought to join yeah
you know church was like the American
Methodist Episcopal Church American
Methodist Episcopal Zion Church we're
coming in from the north and they have
you know they have some resources they
had some backing but they also sort of
were felt to not really
harmonize as well with african-american
Christians in the south who wanted a
more emotional focused type of type of
service who felt that these groups were
getting more doctrinaire a bit more you
know sort of stick in the mud and the
Baptist's actually were seen as as being
you know more able to meet their needs
they got it other groups
what other Christian denominations catch
on look at the leaders there tell you
about a little bit of a later time now
yeah yeah now that's part of the story
and this chapter doesn't do all that
much on that interestingly remember when
we talk about Catholic school systems
there have always been some in some
african-american Catholic converse and
there were some you know you know
outreaches and missions and orders
- that the Catholic school one of the up
shots of the Catholic school systems
remaining in place even after a lot of
the Catholics have moved out was
african-american parents using them as a
place to send their children so that
they would have you know a disciplined
and orderly high academic standard
environment safe environment and that is
actually enough producing a lot of
African American Conference who then
send their kids to Catholic school so
that's kind of an interesting side note
but a much larger proportion would
include churches like the Church of God
and major gamma like an American church
what family what denominational family
does that church I mean you can go into
African American neighborhoods you're
gonna see a lot of the Church of God in
Christ
churches what's what's different from
between them and the Baptists and
Methodists they're the largest of this
this group uses the terms sanctified
when we see that we ought to think
holiness Pentecostal Church of God in
crisis at Pentecostal church they
actually had it had an offshoot which
was a holiness but not Pentecostal
church so we've talked a little bit
about this this is sort of the
denominational landscape though there's
you know things there are black
Lutheran's too you know because the
Missouri Church Lutheran Church Missouri
Synod sorry succeeded in being Clayton
to african-americans in their time but
those tend to be kind of small these
tend to be the really big groupings
what's what's similar then and what's
different from african-american churches
and it's a white Methodists or white
Baptists or or white Pentecostals so
your book talks about this in these
terms it says worship and black churches
shares may need to feel logical and
liturgical premises but few black
services are exactly like their white
counterparts social class plays some
role here if your higher social class
there's kind of a hierarchy here but
again that's similar also or at least
used to be similar for whites
particularly in the south
Baptists were at the bottom of the
pecking order until Pentecostals came
around back at us you were you know
probably middle class you could really
tell that you'd made it the self if you
were an Episcopalian or presbyterian
what else says much of the
distinctiveness of black worship has
roots and patterns developed during the
era of slavery they grew to include
preaching often based on narrative held
together by formulated phrases we've
talked about this before this notion
that remember I likened it to him Eric
like The Odyssey use of stock phrases
you can sort of link things together
into these these quite complex literary
kind of positions narrative and moral
expectation are more common than
doctrinal instruction the congregation
interacts enthusiastically with the
preacher at least if the preacher is
lightest you know if the preacher is
doing well there's a lot of
back-and-forth which is sometimes
missing in white churches open emotional
expression as a common feature and then
it also talks about gospel music and
then it spends quite a bit of time on
and it even talks about you know the
function of the the record industry
play it in there what else do we need to
hit upon oh the role of the preacher why
is the preacher so important in
african-american churches
I mean sometimes people give up preacher
hard time yeah you know there's a
similar dynamic to when we talked about
the Irish priest in an Irish parish
probably one of the few you know
particularly literate well-educated
people used as an interface between the
community and the outside world and
somebody would also play an important
role in deciding things within the
community I mean that gives you an idea
why in the civil rights struggle the
churches were so centrally important
rather than just a political
organizations you know Martin Luther
King was a highly educated guy who I
mean if you actually read his stuff he's
writing about people like Paul Tillich
and you know he invokes st. Augustine
and Thomas Aquinas in his letter from
the Birmingham jail and Ostra gives his
new take on on what natural law means in
terms of the human person very you know
eloquent and literate guy he was able to
be that way in part because he's coming
from a tradition of ministry where a lot
of black leadership is coming from the
churches your book them talks quite a
bit about about where the civil rights
from the most and we only have a bit of
time to discuss this talked about some
of the influences on it with the motif
of liberation
gives you a bit of the history of that
but one of the things that it really
stresses is the civil rights struggle
starts out as partly a political thing
and involves some people who were not
religious but he had a lot of drew in a
lot of religious leadership it also did
not bring in all religious leadership
who was anybody remember who King's
letter to a Birmingham jail is actually
addressed to him okay it's not like a to
the nation as such or you know you jerks
in Montgomery who are you know fire
hosing us or something yeah
who's he writing it's raining militant
religious leaders who are saying you're
doing the wrong thing you're breaking
the law the Bible says don't break the
law even if you don't like what's going
on so he's having to justify himself to
a lot of religious leaders who aren't
involved so we're sitting on the the
side at the same time but your book
points out the influence of Christianity
on the movement was problematic King was
committed to he's a he's a Baptist but
who else does he drive he draws on some
non-christian sources where is he giving
ideas about non-violence from exactly I
mean you know there's this Jesus guy -
it also says a lot of stuff about that
but but you've got Gandhi so he's
bringing in a Hindu religious figure he
also talked about Henry David Thoreau
where we tend to associate with
transcendentalism or with liberal
Christian very liberal Christianity and
then there's you know you can see this
if you read Kings later writers king
himself starts to realize before he dies
that the movement has taken a very
different turn with the shift to - black
power but with people like a book
mentioned Stokely Carmichael you know
Martin Luther King and Malcolm X would
be good Antipodes here although Malcolm
X is a is of course a Muslim figure and
King was was very concerned about the
fact
the movement was becoming more and more
radical more and more willing to
dispense with non-violence and sort of
distinct distancing itself from its
originally larger cushion ruse he writes
a great book called where do we go from
here you only read one book like
actually I'd say that's the book time to
read there's also an interesting
development that takes place those
mobile clothes work with the development
what they call black theology he and
Elbert created the black Messiah is is
you know one that gets brought up a lot
when you hear this notion that Jesus was
black that's where that are you know
that's that's where the trope is coming
from originally not quite as influential
although that sort of popular culture
James cone
tries to develop something like
liberation theology but from an
african-american perspective in his
black theology and black power and that
a number of other things as well so
we're we're closes blessing is by saying
that african-american Baptist and
Methodist churches and their clergy
continue to enjoy prestige and it sort
of leaves open the question of where the
churches are going to go after this
they've become heavily connected over
time with the Democratic Party
you guys remember I mentioned what was
it Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama were
the two frontrunners that was 2008
election the the it began on the
Democratic side like both of them giving
speeches at churches at historically
black churches in Alabama right across
town from each other
will their continued there's some
tensions between in part because these
churches are actually in many respects
more conservative than the party with
which they're aligned so there's some
tensions there
and that's where the book leaves a lot
because that's an open question so